कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
दो कंसेप्ट सीखने वाले हैं जो अगर आप
एडवांस लेवल में मतलबी दुनिया उसके आगे
अगर सीखने वाले हो तो बहुत इंपोर्टेंट है
और यह जो कंसेप्ट है न वह थोड़े मुकाबले
पिछड़ ज्यादा है ग्रामर रिलेटिड से मतलब
क्या कि कल सीखना है एकदम सिंपल है और
उसके लिए आपको थोड़ी मेहनत लेनी पड़ेगी जो
आपको इसको यूज करूंगी और वह कैसे करना है
उसके लिए मैंने क्या किया था यह भी मैं
आपको बताऊंगा तो चलो शुरू करते हैं सबसे
पहले कंसेप्ट देखते हैं वक्त प्रपोजिशन टो
वर्क विद प्रगतिशील तो यह क्या है समझने
के लिए पहले हम थोड़े हमारी इंडियन
लैंग्वेज से थे तो आपको एक सिंपल एक्सांपल
देता हूं कि वह मैं अनीता से प्यार करता
है यह मैं अमित अनीता से प्रेम करता हूं
अभी मैं बोल तेरे मेरे मदन मराठी लिए तो
मराठी में क्या होता है मी अनीता व प्रेम
करतो मतलब मराठी में मैं अनीता तेल प्रेम
करता हूं अभी
मराठी और हिंदी तो वैसे थोड़े मतलब अधिक
लेटेस्ट विषयक उनकी मतलब कि मातृभाषा है व
संस्कृत है फिर भी आप हिंदी में से प्रेम
करते हो मराठी मैं पे प्रेम करते हो तो
कौन सा से यह कौन सा गलत ऐसा कुछ भी नहीं
है दो अलग लैंग्वेजिस है उनके बोलने की वह
तरीके हैं सिमिलर अगर आप इंग्लिश में
देखोगे तो आप बोलते हैं वेट फॉर नहीं था
तो अब यह आपने कभी सोचा कि आई वेट फॉर तक
यू फॉर कहां से है हल्का सा वेट और मनीता
क्यों नहीं कि वर्क व हमने याद रखना
इंग्लिश में बिजनौर वेरी लॉजिकल किशनपोल
हमने याद रखना कि भाई आईएस वैलिड फॉर होता
है ओके अब भोजन में भी ऐसे होता है कि वह
कुछ वर्ष के साथ उनका प्रपोजिशन है तो
जर्मन पर होता है इनवर्टर और अनिल इस
मास्टर फाइनली यहां पर मैं क्लास मुझे कुछ
लोग पूछते हैं कि व्वे इन थिस
क्यों नहीं समझता कि आपने पहले इंग्लिश
ठीक है इसलिए आप ऐसे पूछ रहे हैं जिसकी
मदद टर्न जर्मन होगी वह उल्टा पूछेगा कि
मैं बाहर आई वेट और क्यों नहीं है कि जैसे
मैं हिंदी में अनीता से प्यार करता हूं
क्यों हैं मराठी में अनीता पे प्यार करता
हूं क्यों है उसका कोई आंसर नहीं वैसे ही
इंग्लिश में वेट फॉर है जर्मन में वाटर
आउट तो यह आपको याद रखना पड़ेगा यह हर
लैंग्वेज का अपना-अपना होता है लग रहा है
और पिछले दिनों तक पईन आप जल्दी जाता है
कि वह कि आप जब नए होते हैं जो नया बंदा
आपसे कोई हिंदी में बात कर रहा था है कि
वह मैं अनीता पे प्यार करता हूं तो आप समझ
मिलोगे पर जब आप एडवांस लेवल बहुत और यह
एक्सपेक्ट यू व अनीता से प्यार करता हूं
इसीलिए इंच का थोड़ा ध्यान रखना तो अभी यह
कौन कौन से देश को थोड़े से कि मैंने
लिस्ट दी है कि मैं कुछ कहते हैं कि भाई
आप इस बार - मतलब मैं आई एम वेट फॉर अगर
आप और इफेक्टिव वर्क में याद
अच्छा तो इस इंटरेस्ट गरम मिसल प्यार की
वफ़ा इंग्लिश में आया इंटरेस्टेड इन होता
है समझिए वैसे इंग्लिश में डिपेंड ओं
समथिंग होता है जर्मन में वह अब हम दल फोन
होता है कभी-कभी थोड़ा सा एक जैसा ही होता
है कि मैं इंग्लिश में जो कि मैं बिना
इसका ट्वीट सकते हैं जर्मन में भी वह
इंफोर्मेशन मिट होता है पर वह उस पर हम
रिलाई नहीं करेंगे हम अपना अपना ही सीखते
जाएंगे समय तो फिर प्रॉब्लम क्या होता है
दूसरा क्यों कैंसर तो समझ में आई थी वह यह
याद रखना है तो लॉकर टमाटर चालू करते हैं
तो भेजो करना जो करना आज
जय हनुमान ज्ञान इन थे प्रभु याद नहीं
रहता कि क्या हो जाता है फिर कि एक-एक जब
यूज करने की टाइम आती है तो आप गलती करते
हो तो उसके लिए जो मैंने किया था मैं आपको
बता तो मेरी टिप किया है एक तो क्या करूं
एक साथ रखता कभी मत मारो यह वर्क नहीं
होगा थोड़ी देर के लिए याद रहेगा उसमें भी
अपने की एक्जाम निकाल लोगे बट उसका लॉन्ग
टर्म में यूज नहीं पहले तो हफ्ते में एक
या दो हूं एक या दो नए सिक्कों पर वह पर
सेट करो और उनका सेंटेंस में यूज कर मैंने
वैसे ही याद रखना बबी मुझे कल याद रखना कि
इंटरेस्ट तुरंत मैं क्या यार क्यों कि इस
इंट्रस्टिंग रमेश की ओर 2 इंच इस सेंटेंस
फॉर डिपॉजिट है तो याद आता है यहां
इंटरेस्ट क्लियर है तो फिर आएगा लेकिन इस
मॉडल ऑफ द Android के यहां मैं तेरे आंसर
की राह देख रहा हूं तो मुझे एकदम याद आता
है क्या यहां कि वांट आफ जितने आपके
सेंटेंस वास याद रखोगे उतना आपको इजी
क्या होगा जिसमें मैंने बोला कुछ की लिस्ट
मैंने दीप ही और थोड़े डिस्क्रिप्शन में
दिए हैं वह आप याद कर सकते हैं वह बटाकर
एक साथ रखता है मत भरो इट इज नॉट गोइंग टो
हेल्प मे ओर लौट और सबसे इंपोर्टेंट क्या
है कि वक्त डायरेक्ट ट्रांसमिशन नहीं डोंट
फॉरगेट हुए कि इंग्लिश में सोच और उसका
लाइट कंडीशन किया ऐसा मत करो यह विल मेक
मिस्टेक्स कंडक्ट समझ में अगर यह सब समझ
गए हैं तो नेक्स्ट कंसेप्ट स्थित थोड़ी सी
रिलेटेड है पर बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग है वह नो
मैन वर्क फ्रंट डूंगर मतलब क्या नाम से
अगर आप देखोगे नान और वर्ग का जोड़ हम कर
रहे हैं तो इसमें क्या होता है कभी-कभी
कितना होता है वर्ग होता है टूगेदर होते
हैं कभी-कभी ना उसका मीनिंग वाले भोजन है
तो इसके लिए हम हिंदी के अपने कंसेप्ट यूज
करेंगे कि इसको सीखने के लिए रेस्ट करने
के लिए मुहावरा है सबको मुहावरे यार पता
है क्या बोलते हैं एक मुहावरा हिंदी में
खोलना तो मेरी आंखें खुल गई थी
इसका मतलब क्या कि कल तक मैं ऐसे आंखें
बंद करके चल रहा था क्या नहीं मुझे कुछ तो
मेरी गलती समझ में आई मैं कुछ तो मतलब आई
अंडरस्टैंड समथिंग तो यहां पर देखो आंखें
एक वर्ड है कि वह पापा आई खुंगा * ओपन
प्रसिद्ध एक साथ है तो उसका और एक मीनिंग
बन गया फिर कमर टूटना कि कमर टूटना मतलब
आपकी खुद की एक्चुअली बैक नहीं है ब्रेक
हो रही है कि वह मेरी पूरी हिम्मत ही मैं
हार्ड है तो यह जो होते हैं इनको मुहावरे
बोलते हैं जो वर्ड एक्सल मुहावरों के जो
वर्ड्स है उनके खुद के अलग मीनिंग है पर
रोचक एक साथ आते हैं तो एक नया मीनिंग
बनता है तो अभी देखो फिर से इसमें क्या
याद रखना है कि अपने खुद के नए मुहावरे
नहीं बनाने हैं अभी क्या होता किसी को
मेरे खुद की मदरटिंचर मैंने बोला मराठी है
कभी-कभी क्या होता है कि कुछ मौजूद है जो
मां मराठी में होते हैं व हिंदी जैसे ही
होते तो कभी के ट्रांसफर के चल जाता है कि
जिसे हिंदी में खेलना है मराठी में भी
बॉलीवुड हैं और अगर मैं यहां पर अफसर
कि हमारे मराठी में दांत किसी पर गुस्सा
याद रखें तो दांत उस पर दांत धरना बोलते
हैं तो वह मराठी में दाने होता है इसका
मतलब हिंदी में हो गए से नहीं आता तो वह
कॉमेडी लगेगा रेड तो इसीलिए हमेशा याद
रखना कि आपने मदर टंग नहीं है उन्होंने जो
बनाया है वह याद रखो आपके जो हिंदी वाले
हैं या इवन इंग्लिश वाले हैं लिटरल
ट्रांसलेशन मत करना कल से समझ में आए तो
थोड़े से यहां के इनके मुहावरे देखते हैं
कुछ एकदम मतलब रिलेट कर सकते हो ऐसे कुछ
नए कुछ सेलेक्ट कर सकते हो मैं आपको बताता
हूं कि वही आईने बैरसिया रोड मुश्किल है
या फिर लाइन अभी स्टिकर ऑइल ऐड कीजिए मतलब
केम टो क्लियर इंपोर्टेंट रोल के एगो एक
बहुत बड़ा रोल प्ले करता है ऐसे और फिर
दूसरा अवसर सफल स्टे हैं मतलब मोड वांट टू
बी और विटामिन इसमें कोई दो राय है यह
नहीं कि ऐसा होता है या फिर फ्रंट तो और
तुम चलाओ
है मतलब क्या कि किसी चीज की जिम्मेदारी
उठाना किसी चीज की जिम्मेदारी लेना कि
वहां यह मेरी सिंह इसके लिए मैं जिम्मेदार
है या फिर
कि Bigg Boss टर्न्ड अराउंड इन थे मोस्ट
प्रॉमिनेंट मतलब किसी चीज की कीमत चुका
रहा हम बोलते हिंदी में भी वह इंटरेस्ट
मॉर्निंग इसकी कीमत तो चुकानी पड़ेगी सौंठ
और 10,000 जर्मन ठंडक अभी कैंसर कि यह
सिर्फ प्रेस है तो यह आपको क्या करना होगा
कि याद ही करनी होंगी तो और जैसे अपने
हिंदी में भी देखा होगा कि वही आपको हींग
मैं आपको अभी पूछा कि इंग्लिश के बीच
प्रेस बताओ तो भी आपको टाइम लगेगा पर वह
छोड़ो अगर आप स्कूल में नहीं अगर आप यह
रेमिडी नॉर्टन स्कूल आपको घर में मौजूद कि
हिंदी के बीच मुहावरे बताओ तो मैं आपको
टाइम लगेगा क्योंकि वह ज्यादा जो आप ए गुड
नाइट में यूज है वहीं आप बोलोगी इसीलिए यह
चीज है कि जो यूज के साथ ही आएंगी लोगों
पर और किसी भी भाषा के वह कितने सारे हो
सकते कि लोग डरते हैं क्योंकि और मैनेजर
बुक देखा उसमें इतने सारे है अगर फैमिली
के देखोगे तो भी आप बोलोगे क्या रितेश है
तो डोंट वरी आपको सारे मुंह में आने की
जरूरत नहीं है जिस
मैं तुम्हारे आपको उस लेवल पर अपने आप को
एक्सप्रेस करने के लिए जरूरी है उस या को
आनी चाहिए और फिर उसको याद कैसे कर रहे
हैं फिर से वही ट्रिक है कि बाबा हफ्ते
में एक ही अर्थ हफ्ते में एक या दो करने
हैं और जैसे मैंने बोला कि रावण दहन सिर्फ
मुहावरा याद रखना उसका सेंटेंस में यूज
याद रखो मैं कुछ व्यूअर्स आपको बताता हूं
तो आपको एकदम सिंपल कि महक मैं कैसे करता
ओके तो सबसे पहले कि बाबा आ और इसे
इंस्टाल पूछते हैं मतलब कि किसी चीज पर
घड़ी को रख यह मेरा मत है तो स्ट्रॉ दिन
स्टंट डांस मोटर्स पर आपको विशेष केस कि
बाबा मदर टंग बहुत इंपोर्टेंट है या फिर
आप सब्सक्राइब कर सकते हैं मतलब इसमें कोई
दो राय नहीं उससे बात मतलब को उसमें कोई
पॉइंट ही नहीं उसके उस पर चर्चा करने का
वक्त तो क्या होगा एस्टेट ऑफिसर्स पॉइंट
पर डांस
के दौरान फकीर वन तो इजी है उसमें क्या इस
बात का
आप समझ गए या फिर डिफर आंतों और तुम
प्रांगन मतलब क्या कि वह किसी चीज की
जिम्मेदारी तरफ से सिर्फ लेना मतलब या तो
मैंने का ध्यान रखें कि भी वियर में संधि
खैरान तो अब तुम फिर उधर फिर हल
तंत्रज्ञान मतलब हमने अपने जो भी अपना बी
है वह उसकी जिम्मेदारी खुद लेनी पड़ेगी और
फिर एनरोल अपील मतलब कि रिमोटेस्ट
प्रॉपर्टीस पेंट एंड ड्रॉइंग रूम्स
अवेलेबल कि मुझे अपनी मदर टंग है वह अपने
लाइफ में बहुत बड़ा रोल प्ले करती है अगर
आप ऐसे उसको यूज करोगे ना तो हम आपको जब
एक्ट्रेस आपके जब भी आप कुछ अगर आप अपना
ओपिनियन लिख रहे हो या किसी से बात कर रहे
हो और तरफ लेना है हां दिस टाइम रिलेटिव
में दिन है कि न्यूज़ डेट है तो इसे लिए
डायरेक्ट करंट मत मारो मैंने जैसे यह
डिसक्रिप्शन में मैंने और थोड़े से दिए
हैं अब आपको इंटरनेट पैसे बहुत सारे मिल
जाएंगी ड्रॉ ए
कि हर कोई सीखने की कोशिश मत करो जो आपको
रीड कर सकते हो वैसे-वैसे सीखते जाओ
जैसे-जैसे आप आगे जाओगे आप नए सीखते जाओगे
और जितना यूज करोगे उतना डायरेक्टिव उसको
मतलब अपने सेंटेंस में उसको अपडेट कर
पाऊंगी आज हमने दो कंसेप्ट सी पहले कौन सी
थी वर्गित प्रपोजिशन की ख्वाइश वाटर आओ और
दूसरी अभी आपने देखिए कि नो मैन व फ्रंट
होंगे मतलब क्या कि वह अवसर अथवा फर्स्ट
हैं तो यह दोनों विकल्प क्या है कि कल सैफ
निकल सिंपल है हमने देखी कि वह हिंदी में
जो थी वहीं है कि मैं अनीता से प्यार करता
हूं और यह फिर कि वह मेरी आंखें खुली हुई
यह तो हमें हिंदी में इंग्लिश में देखा है
व्हाट इज़ इंपॉर्टेंट कि वह बाहर आप एक
कितने ऐसे कितने प्रैक्टिस करते हो मैं तो
बोलता हूं कि हफ्ते में दो बार दिन दो भी
नहीं एक ही को एक वर्क विद प्रीपोजिशन और
एक सोमेश्वर प्रॉब्लम भी करोगे ना तीन चार
हफ्तों में आपके पास इन न
शुरू हो जाएंगे मुझे आशा है कि आपको एकदम
समझ में आए होगी हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
एपिसोड में नेहरू